madame à quoi ce merci d'être en direct
avec nous alors vous êtes bloqués au
maroc depuis combien de temps et comment
vivez-vous cette situation particulière
alors bonjour
pour ma part je suis bloqué depuis le 23
mars date à laquelle mon billet retour
en fête a été annulée mais j'essaye de
revenir en france depuis l'annoncé faite
par le maroc de la fermeture des
frontières
donc depuis mi mars alors il ya des
français qui ont été rapatriés d'autres
comme vous qui n'ont pas été quels sont
les critères de choix justement pour
rapatrier les français qui sont bloqués
au maroc
alors c'est vrai qu'il ya eu beaucoup de
chiffres qui ont été annoncés donc il
faut savoir que le maroc en fait à a
décrété la fermeture des frontières le
ensuite la mise en place de l'état
d'urgence à partir du 22 donc avancer en
fait il ya beaucoup de gens qui ont pu
avoir des billets et rentrer via des
vols commerciaux et les rapatriements en
fait on commençait qu'à partir de la
mise en place de l'état d'urgence
sanitaire
donc depuis fin mars il faut savoir qu
elle très peu de vols et haut niveau en
fait des des choix faits par les
consulats notamment pour permettre à ces
personnes de rentrer il invoque des
raisons sanitaires
en tout cas pour beaucoup c'est ce qu'on
nous a dit aujourd'hui on estime qu'il
reste encore beaucoup de personnes qui
sont dans des états quand même très
critique et qui n'ont pas réussi à avoir
accès à ces vols de rapatriement mis en
place par la france
est-ce que vous vous sentez abandonnée
par le gouvernement français
complètement oui parce qu'aujourd'hui en
fait je vois beaucoup de personnes parce
qu'on est aujourd'hui solidaire via
différents groupes qui ont été mis en
place par par quelques personnes au
début est aujourd'hui en fait on se
donne des informations des informations
qu'on n'a pas de la part parfois des
consulats et oui on se sent abandonnés
parce qu'à des personnes on a des
témoignages quotidien de personnes qui
n'ont plus de traitements qui ont des
pathologies quand même très grave avec
des risque létal est aujourd'hui ces
personnes non non aucune information sur
un potentiel rapatriement ma
gray leur état de santé très critique
donc oui on se sent abandonnée et que
vous du le consulat j'imagine que vous
êtes en contact avec les consulats les
ans pas attaquer ce qu'elle vous
répondent quand vous leur dites que vous
êtes bloqués au maroc depuis un mois
maintenant
mais en fait ils nous donnent
systématiquement alors quand on appelle
souvent on n'a pas de réponse donc il
faut vraiment insister pour avoir une
réponse de la part de dd des personnes
qui travaillent au consulat après bien
sûr on dénigre pas on sait qu'ils ont
beaucoup d'appels et qui font ce qu'ils
peuvent
maintenant on a très peu de réponses et
quand on envoie des mails on a démêlé
générique qui nous indique en fait les
mêmes démarches à savoir s'inscrire sur
ariane se rapprocher du consulat de
notre circonscription et patienter voilà
aujourd'hui les réponses qu'on a
après pour les personnes qui sont aimés
re donc les marocains résidant à
l'étranger qui ne disposent pas de la
nasse de la nationalité
on nous dit clairement que ces personnes
ne sont pas prioritaires donc là aussi
on a beaucoup de témoignages où on nous
indique que les personnes aiment héros
ne sont pas prioritaires pour les
rapatriements aujourd'hui en france en
tout cas c'est moi personnellement ce
qu'on m'a dit pour ma mère qui est
nerveux qui ne disposent pas de la
nationalité française
on m'a dit que ce n'était pas
prioritaire pour un rapatriement alors
vous le disiez à l'instant vous êtes en
contact avec d'autres aux français avec
les réseaux sociaux qu'est ce que vous
faites justement pour faire un peu
bouger des choses parce que
manifestement le gouvernement ne le fait
pas vraiment alors justement donc on
essaye déjà pour commencer de donner des
informations aux personnes qui se
sentent aussi démunis qui n'ont pas
forcément accès à tous les outils aux
réseaux sociaux à une connexion internet
ça il faut savoir qu'il y en a beaucoup
aujourd'hui qui n'ont pas accès à tout
ça donc on essaye avec ce qu'on peut
comme comme outil de pouvoir les aider
les faire inscrire si on peut que ce
soit sur ariane ou sur les différents
formulaires qui existe et surtout
finalement d'avoir une écoute et d'être
solidaire donc ça peut aider une
personne à recueillir des fonds pour
répondre à un besoin de santé acheter
des médicaments trouver un logement
voilà c'est toutes ces aides finalement
que toutes les personnes qui sont dans
ces groupes essaye d'apporter essaie
d'apporter aux autres dz qu'on n'a pas
finalement de notre propre gouvernement
alors très rapidement madame à quoi vous
avez peut-être directrice adjointe
d'année
en france on sait que le personnel
soignant en français est tabou est ce
que vous êtes un peu en contact avec vos
collègues
alors oui j'essaye d'être en contact et
notamment avec avec ma directrice qui
comprend la situation mais qui elle-même
finalement ne comprends pas pourquoi vu
la situation aujourd'hui que connaissent
les ehpad en france avec toute l'aide
dont on a besoin des personnes qui
travaillent au sein de ces personnes
vulnérables ne soit pas rapatrier on a
des infirmiers on a décliné on a des
médecins qui aujourd'hui sont bloqués
qui ne demande qu'à rentrer pour aider
et ces personnes ne sont pas
prioritaires non plus
dallas la coiffe merci d'avoir été en
direct avec nous je rappelle peut-être
franco-marocaine bloqués au maroc et
directrice adjointe d'un nepad merci
mais